bill Thomas where did you get the title
Club fed Club Med Club fed I it occurred
to me that a lot of a lot of the time on
Capitol Hill is spent not doing the work
of the public but really really playing
or playing at being a public servant and
the and the title sort of grew naturally
out of that out of that thought what
does it mean I said but maybe some of
your viewers know this but most people
don't realize that the typical
congressional workweek lasts from
sometime Tuesday morning to maybe
sometimes Thursday afternoon and the
weekend the congressional weekend is a
little longer in most cases in the
congressional workweek and club fed it
is meant to suggest that all of the
activity that goes on in Capitol Hill is
not does not really wouldn't follow
under fall under the heading of public
service but self service and in in many
cases recreation let me yeah from time
to time take the other side just so sure
purpose of discussion if a member we're
sitting here with a say whoa mr. Thomas
you don't know what you're talking about
I leave here on Thursday I fly back to
my district I spend Friday Saturday
Sunday Monday morning in constituent
service going to dinners speaking to
service clubs handshaking office hours
town meetings I'm exhausted
mm-hmm I'm sure they are I what I tried
to do here was write an entertaining
book about a subject that most people
take I think to seriously
politics I began with the assumption
that politics is show business and for
the most part politicians are our actors
or performance artists some some in the
best sense some are really nothing more
than lounge acts but a lot of what is
called work on Capitol Hill is really
performance and I'm sure they get they
get tired after a weekend back in their
districts or wherever they are raising
money or trying to influence people but
it's not it's not work in the end the
way that most people think of work it's
perform
it's acting it's raising money it's
putting on a show where are you from I'm
from Chicago grew up here in Washington
however and have lived here off and on
for most of my life where did you go to
school I went to school to University of
Washington in Seattle what'd you study
comparative literature taught taught
there for a while taught at Goucher
College in Baltimore until around 1975
and have been writing ever since worked
for the Baltimore Sun was a reporter for
the Sun for about five years worked at
Congressional quarterly worked at roll
call and still occasionally do some
things for roll call and most recently
have worked for the LA Times Sunday
magazine what is roll call roll call is
a how can I put this roll call is a
newspaper it's a little like The Wall
Street Journal it covers goings-on in
capital come down a couple of times a
week it combines a little bit of nuts
and bolts Hill reporting with reporting
on Hill sociology it's a little bit like
The Hollywood Reporter in some sense it
keeps track of the industry and it
reports on personalities in the news
capital it has fun with politics how
long did you work there I started there
when a Jim Glassman and I came to roll
call after Arthur Levitt bought it in
nineteen was at 86 I think 86 or 87 then
stayed with roll call until about 1990
when I got a contract to write an
earlier book you say in the book that
and you think said you Dan you used to
own real great guy you basically you say
also that in an interviewing City Dane
that he wants to go back to the old days
I think he does I did a created roll
call in in 1959 it Sid had actually been
working in Hollywood doing some work for
The Hollywood Reporter and the Hollywood
Citizen news I don't know if that exists
any longer but what sort of a Hollywood
community newspaper and Sid Sid liked
politics but but he but he realized very
quickly that there wasn't any any sort
of community newspaper for Capitol Hill
in the early 50s or mid 50s and he came
here and started roll call
actually discovered a lot of a lot of
big talents along the way and putting
together the early the early roll call
one of whom was Mark Russell whom he
discovered working in a in a in a bar a
strip bar
in in Washington the club Maryland and
Sid nurtured nurtured mark Russell Mark
Russell did some writing for the early
roll-call and there's still great
friends but the point I want to make was
that he said that he has sold it he sold
roll call in in 1986 1988 85 86 to
Arthur Levitt who's now the SEC chairman
she said for $500,000 somewhere and then
Arthur Levitt sold it to the economist
for 15 million somewhere in the
neighborhood of 15 million from 1986 to
what 1993 or so that made some money how
could I mean how could you go from a
publication on Capitol Hill of being
worth a half a million dollars to being
worth 15 million dollars
well advertising picked up less but
let's put it that way
roll you advertising comfort a lot of
the advertising in roll call a lot of
advertising in newspapers that cover
Capitol Hill is advertising meant to
influence Congress corporate
corporations speaking to legislators and
speaking to lawmakers a lot of sort of
corporate I guess you might call them
corporate vanity ads ads intended to
influence opinion makers law makers in
one way or another and you thought you
find a lot of this sort of thing in
National Journal Congressional quarterly
roll call and there's a new publication
on Capitol Hill called the hill now you
see a lot of it in there are you a party
member Republican or Democrat no
independent what do you think of
politicians in general just personally
personally I find them fascinating to
tell you the truth I find I find people
to go into politics very interesting
people it it's a mystery to me what
makes them tick and I love to talk to
them about their ambitions and where
they're coming from I had an opportunity
a couple of years ago to cover the
congressional orientation for the LA
Times magazine and spent about a week
and a half with new members of Congress
it was interesting to watch them become
in effect congressmen and Congresswomen
over the period of this two or three
week training session
they they came to Capitol Hill one day
we're kind of raw rookies you can see
they were intimidated many of them a
little awed by the whole thing
but after they're after really being
introduced to the club as it were you
could watch you watch them become become
members of Congress what motivates
people to go into politics I couldn't I
couldn't begin to tell you but I like to
watch
politicians perform I like I like to
watch them in the act of being
politicians I remember a friend of mine
told me a story once about having a
conversation with Charlie Rose
congressman our congressman Charlie not
we should make that distinction not to
talk show hosts the congressman from
North Carolina very powerful guy on
Capitol Hill he's head of the House
Administration Committee in fact runs
the congressional orientation program
but this friend was having a
conversation with Rose and behind Rose
was c-span playing and it was a tape of
the previous day's activity on Capitol
Hill and every time Rose came on the
television set this was a set behind
Rose now he would stop his conversation
and turn around watch himself when he
was finished speaking get back to his
conversation it's it's that sort of
thing it's that I guess you might call
it a psychological impulse to to be a
politician that I find really
interesting about politics and about
people to go into it when was the last
word written by you that's a good
question
sometime in maybe the middle of June end
of June somewhere in there is the what's
happened that you wrote there well
what's happened I tried to squeeze in as
much as I possibly can as I could in
about whitewater and health care let me
at the last minute what I'm getting at
is let me pick a chapter 13 tiny qual Oh
mm-hmm
before Tony Coelho came back to this
town you wrote a lot about him you
interviewed yeah well Tony koala is very
interesting guy when Tony koala left
left Congress under a cloud in 1989 I'm
some of your viewers may recall that
Tony Cuellar was involved in a
junk bond deal with a Beverly Hills
investment broker and was writer at the
time that Jim Wright had gotten into
trouble Tony Coelho I for whatever
reason decided it would be better just
to leave rather than have to go through
an ethics committee hearing he had
befriended John Mac a lobbyist who had
he'd been an investment partner with Mac
and a couple of real estate deals in
California Mac had worked for right and
Mac at revealed in Washington Post story
had beaten up a woman after a in
Virginia seventeen years earlier and
gotten a very light prison sentence
after the after after his trial and
right it helped with lessening the
sentence apparently in Mack's case and
12-hours defending Mac in 1989 was a
very bad year for Democrats and things
were getting very messy and Cuellar had
Cuellar had left Congress and he went to
work for Wertheim Schroeder a New York
investment firm and I thought he'd make
a very interesting profile story and I
did an interview with him and an article
about him in Manhattan Inc clay Felker's
magazine which no longer exists and in
the five years since I'd done that story
koala had become very important to
figure in New York Investment Banking
and I thought it might be interesting to
look at tony coelho is the perfect
example in a way of what happens to
somebody who's that powerful on Capitol
Hill in a life after Congress and I went
and interviewed him last knocked over I
think it was at in New York in his
office and here we started talking about
politics and investing and you could see
in the five years or so he'd been
working in New York that he'd you could
you could see him chomping at the bit to
get back into politics he told me at the
time he'd been talking to people like
Newt Gingrich and Bill Clinton and he'd
really never lost touch with Washington
he lives in Alexandria which is not too
far from Capitol Hill and he spent his
weekends here and tried to get back to
Washington as often as he could and we
talked about money we talked about his
background his his Jesuit school
seminary training his relationship with
Bob Hope which he credits with saving
him from his few early mistakes that he
made in his life and actually he credits
Bob Hope with suggesting to get into
politics and he said when he had some
problems in pow
in 1989 he called both Bob Hope asked
him what he should do and he said hope
suggested that he get into Investment
Banking such a source of good advice but
we got into money
can I read a quote oh yeah please yeah I
think this is your quote i buy underlies
this what is government Tony quality
quality yeah it's a money game but
everybody in Congress is embarrassed to
talk about it they're embarrassed by the
money they give out embarrassed by the
money they raise embarrassed to vote for
their own salaries to me it was a big
facade everybody knew what they were
doing they just pretended they were
doing something else that the game they
were playing was about public policy
when in reality it's all about money
well it's hard to disagree with that
considering that members of Congress
have to raise about seventeen thousand
dollars a week in order to pay for
re-election campaigns it is about money
me are you are you agreeing with him
that everything over there is about
money it's about access to money it's
about I'd say if you want to stay in on
the job it's about raising enough money
to be re-elected I think the the the the
job of a congressman has two jobs or a
senator has two jobs performing a public
service and if he's interested in
staying on the job getting reelected and
that effort starts on day one you again
going back to the freshman orientation
program that I that I witnessed a couple
of years ago you can see that interest
in Erna in raising money and trying to
find out ways to raise money earn money
for your re-election campaign start on
day one sure it's a politics is all
about money tony coelho knows that and
here's probably one of the biggest money
raisers and Democratic Party recent
Democratic Party history it's the public
at large as you've traveled around and
talked about your book and know this and
I don't think they I don't I think
they're getting wise I think they're
getting wise and they know that
something has to I think people the
voting public whatever you want to call
that group out there that elects members
of Congress and the Senate
year after year after year but I think
these people in the in the out in the
country are realizing that something has
to be done to control
access to money and the way money has
become so much a part of politics and it
seems as though the best they've come up
with so far whether its constitutional
or not as term limits I think people are
upset about the way money is spent and
what money is spent on and the way money
has become so much a part of what
politics is today tony coelho probably
wouldn't have said what he said to me a
year ago today there was a profile of
him recently in one of the papers and it
was New York Times or Washington Post I
can't recall which very very careful
about what he said but I thought that
was a pretty revealing comment is this a
an honest town well truth in Washington
of course is always fluid I mean truth
truth here tends to be a spoken truth
tends to be what works I polit politics
is the art of motivating people to do
what you want them to do whether it's
vote for you support an issue turnout at
a rally appear at a demonstration this
is all part of the Washington Washington
show business I mean Washington is a
town for performing whether it's
performing in a demonstration in front
of the Supreme Court rallying around
some cause on the Capitol Steps
appearing at a luncheon speech at the
National Press Club talking to
constituents entertaining constituents
putting flags out in the hallway
Washington is a town full of actors of
one sort or another in acting is the art
of presenting illusions and that's what
politics really is or has become you say
this is these are your words financial
service not eloquence is the ultimate
measure of success in Congress what's
that mean
well once again providing constituent
service no constituent service can take
many forms as you know providing giving
people back home the money they the
money they need to build airports roads
factories constituent service is helping
people locate their social security
checks and constituent service is
building super highways the very funny
story about Robert Byrd when he was
running for re-election in the late 80s
against a sort of an upstart
West Virginia lawyer the upstart West
Virginia lawyer
J wolf decided that bird wasn't bringing
enough money back to the state and he
wouldn't he would teach him a lesson by
walking the state which is a typical
campaign move but he'd walked the state
of West Virginia from the Panhandle to
the Ohio River and to demonstrate to the
people that his commitment would be to
to bring money more money to West
Virginia faster than bird who burden me
doing it and bird was in declining in
age and and burgess wasn't providing
West Virginia with the kind of money
that it had been used to getting from
the government every every move this guy
would walk a mile and bird would fund
another highway every every everyday the
guy was on his track across West
Virginia Byrd funneled more and more
money into the state finally by the time
the guy the poor fellow J wolf gets to
the Ohio River Byrd had had dumped about
16 million dollars into into West
Virginia so bird one he lost that's
that's how members of Congress get
reelected you do you do financial favors
for the folks back home whether the
favors are for individuals and small or
for fat cats and large favors that's one
of the ways you ingratiate yourself to
the people this book guys put out by
Scribner
Scribner how did it all start well it
started with a conversation that I had
with my agent Henry do now about maybe
two and a half years ago we're kicking
around the subject of a book on Capitol
Hill book on Washington at the time I
had just come back from Moscow where I
had been working on an earlier book and
it finished just finished that book on
capitalism in in the new Russia and we
were joking about Russia's attempts to
become a democracy and and one thing led
to another and the idea for a book on
Capitol Hill was generated and we went
to talk to an editor at Scribner who
liked the idea and at the time we were
sort of kicking around this notion that
1994 Clinton had not been elected yet it
was early in the in the primary season
as I recall or maybe maybe in the summer
turns the end of the primary season and
we we all sort of got the idea that the
1994 congressional
election would be a referendum of some
sort on congressional behavior
congressional ethics and nobody had any
idea at the time certainly none of us
had any idea at the time that it would
become the sort of national referendum
on Washington that it did it's become
dedicated for Brendan who's that as my
son how it where is he
he lives here in Washington Hey and and
he goes to high school here and how old
a bourbon Maryland 16 years old works on
the works in the high school newspaper
gonna do the same thing no no no he's
good writer some of the things in here
come pretty close to home for this
network and I want to read one and you
never never met each other so no never
the gallery also contains eight remote
controlled television cameras bolted
down at key angles that cover the place
from wall to wall as if it were a
convenience store in a high crime
neighborhood which in a way is what it
is what are you talking about well in a
sense Capitol Hill is one-stop shopping
for people looking around for favors and
for course it's a place where
congressmen are all these members of
Congress always shopping around for
financial favors from supporters but
Capitol Hill is a dangerous a dangerous
place you you can't I I was reminded
immediately whenever first time I saw
the viewer I should say television
camera now they're not ours they're not
yours they belong to the house and they
belong to the Senate you lease them no
they belong to the House and Senate you
run it
no they run it all we do is plug in like
any other news organization you plug in
just plug in anybody has access to
anybody has access to that well when I
saw the cameras in there I was reminded
immediately of a 7-eleven and the way
when you go into the 7-eleven to buy a
burrito burger or something like that
you're you're being followed by this
little mini camp and the the cameras
move there are no cameramen in there
they sort of move independent of any
human human operator and it immediately
struck me this place is just like a
7-eleven and these are like anti-theft
devices and when you think of the sort
of place Capitol Hill is if if you live
in Washington now it's a fair Washington
is a fairly dangerous did either a
couple of car jacks and jackings every
week and
violent crime all over the place Capitol
Hill is is sort of America's the most
politicized free fire zone in a sense a
very dangerous neighborhood and the
danger takes many forms and those
cameras just caught my imagination you
say most senators it was clear by now
had no idea what they were voting on
which is the way Congress usually works
I you know I think the health care bill
illustrated this pretty well people were
confessing at one point there during the
health care debate that they had no idea
was in any of these bills they didn't
hadn't read them they hadn't they hadn't
had time to really form intelligent
opinions about anything legislation was
flying so fast and furious it as it
often does members will confess often
after they leave they'll they'll tell
you how how chaotic how impossible it is
to to read things to know exactly what
you're doing all the time and they make
these confessions conveniently when they
decide to retire and go into lobbying or
some other allied profession back in the
back you say that in nineteen ninety two
of the hundred and twenty one departing
members of Congress more than forty
percent followed the path of least
resistance into quote government
relations unquote otherwise known as
lobbying record speaks for itself there
a huge number of course that was a huge
number of departing members some of the
some of the former members who are in
lobbying will tell you that the field is
becoming so saturated now with former
members that it's difficult even for the
most plugged in X members of the House
and Senate to sell their services to a
two bidders after after they get out of
office there are just a lot of ex
members looking to do what they do best
or no best and that's Lobby there
they're buddies back in back in Congress
I remember guy Vanderjagt said something
very funny to me he had I think he was
he'd been in office for maybe fifteen
terms I'm not quite sure but a long time
a member of the Republican member of the
House and he was defeated in the primer
and he said well he said it took me a
while to get used to that it was it was
depressing and and all but he said I
realized something the guy who beat me
did me a favor and did himself a favor
he tripled
both of our salaries there are lots of
there lots of ways for congressmen who
lose and primaries or general elections
to get to come down from there from the
sorrow of their defeat but a lot of them
stay in Washington doing what they've
always done which is selling influence
or being available for consultation with
people with money what impact does it
have that members can always go back on
the floor of the house anytime they
wanted I think that's amazing well of
course that's a good way to lobby other
members to do with people who pay you to
deliver their message want you to do if
they are allowed to lobby suppose well
come on they're there their influence is
felt they can lobby in the cloakroom
they can Lobby in the hallways they can
go and sit and listen it's they're
members of a club it's a it's a it's a
club and you belong as you play the game
according to the rules of the system
you're a lifetime member but a member
recently who had served three months in
jail Larry Smith from Florida came back
to the floor in the cloakroom and the
speaker ordered hims to stop doing what
I was doing I don't know what he was
doing but you know it didn't look good
reporters probably saw and but it goes
on all the time you say lawmakers love
when disaster strikes money you know
money from heaven earthquakes fires this
gives this gives members of Congress an
opportunity to tak private bills this is
this is one of the great charades on
Capitol Hill I talk about the
Mississippi River flood in nineteen
blessed year in 93 it took Congress over
two and a half weeks to appropriate
money need it to keep these people from
going under all up and down the
Mississippi Valley while members fought
one another over over private spending
bills that were that were tacked on to
this thing there were bills to renovate
railroad stations and bills to employ
unemployed gang members and to teach
people how to do this and then the other
thing meanwhile these poor families
these poor farm families out in the
Mississippi Valley are treading water
waiting for Congress to help them it
became a huge scandal but
disasters are an opportunity to it's
like it's like congressional bingo in a
way it's an opportunity to tack on all
kinds of private spending things to
emergency relief legislation earlier and
your introduction you say that the
interests are joined at the wallet - 535
Congressional profit centers mm-hmm we
mean by that they make a profit in these
office well they have to raise money and
you can look at that you can call that
whatever you want
congressional offices members of
Congress as I said have to make 15 16 17
18 20 thousand dollars a week to pay for
their re-election campaigns most of that
money going to meet buying media buying
advertising you're not talking about
every member of Congress right because
seventeen thousand we're talking we're
talking about what we're talking average
some of these races some Senate races
cost we'll look at the huffington
feinstein race in California but you're
lumping the Senate and the house
together I mean lumping the Senate in
the house together and taking an average
Senate Senate races are more expensive
depending on the state depending on the
size of the State House races can run
anywhere from a couple of hundred
thousand dollars to over a million
dollars Huffington spent Michael
Huffington spent 400 our record four
point three I think million dollars to
win US House seat in 92 he's spending 17
18 million who knows how much on his
Senate race in California this year it's
expensive and if you want to win and win
convincingly it can be very expensive on
the back of the book you have a some
endorsements one of them is from Bill
Proxmire by the way that was that your
idea or scriveners don't know don't know
why scribblers gets in touch but
publishers get into they send books out
to people in a book is written I
suggested some names I can't remember I
suggested Proxmire not as somebody might
find this interesting but they had some
names and but they publishing a show
business to the publisher sent the
manuscript a book around her galleys of
the book around to lots of people he
says I thought my 31 years in the Senate
had taught me all I wanted to laugh
about in Washington until I read Club
fed how wrong I was Bill Thomas makes
our capital even more astaire
funny than I had ever realized did you
mean this book to be funny I meant it to
be entertaining I'll tell you a Capitol
Hill is a great source of entertainment
I think one of the reasons that people
probably watch c-span I know it's one of
the reasons i watch when something
interesting on the hill is going on it's
fabulous entertainment
I have stone once told me he said look I
was talking him in connection with
something I was doing a few years ago
and he we were talking about how amusing
politics can be and he said the greatest
source of amusement in politics is the
public record look at the public record
and you will become addicted to the to
the things that are the humor it
contains and this I find that to be true
but I wanted the book to be entertaining
and I wanted people to learn something
from it and be informed but I wanted
them to you know in in in literature you
want people to turn keep turning the
pages and the way to do that is to keep
their interest and keep them keep them
entertained and informed probably at the
same time it's quite a track for what do
you find people to be people's favorite
chapter I've gotten a lot of a lot of
comments on there's a chapter in there
called Caesars Palace on the Potomac I
don't know how long I've heard the term
Hollywood on the Potomac applied to
Washington but it really it's more like
Las Vegas considering the money that has
to be brought in and the kind of this
sort of like I like to call call it
lounge act type style entertainment that
goes on but but it's more like Las Vegas
it's more like a casino than a movie
studio older obviously there are a lot
of movie studio aspects to it it was as
well but there's a prayer that begins
that chapter the Senate chaplain says a
prayer I'm going to read it as you wish
sovereign Lord of history and the
nation's we pray for the senators
running for re-election he's retiring by
the way mr. gryszek reverend Halverson
give it give wisdom to those who direct
their campaigns give the Senators
special persuasion in speech and provide
wherever needed adequate campaign funds
we pray in his name
through whom thou dost promise to supply
all our needs according to your riches
in glory amen
can I get you this was that's a prayer
it's a prayer on the Senate floor found
in the Congressional Record I mean I
wasn't there at the time but it was in
the Congressional Record I'm assuming it
was set on the President on the Senate
floor to open a session of that August
body was it said with a straight face
that it means uh was a prayer I'm
assuming eyes were you know bent towards
heaven at least on some people's parts
you know if you if you watch members of
the House and Senate when these prayers
are usually said they're talking to one
another and doing all sorts of things
but at this particular time I'm sure
they were paying attention these are the
kinds of prayers that that members of
Congress fully expect to be answered and
of course for the more successful ones
they are give wisdom to those who direct
their campaigns give the Senators
special persuasion and speech and
provide wherever needed adequate
campaign funds by the way is one side
better than the other one side meaning
riddled Democrat conservative Republican
Democrats in what sense in any sense
better at more honest its politic it's
all politics there's a you know there is
a difference between the two parties it
goes it goes beyond nametags but when it
comes right down to it they all they're
there to preserve a system which keeps
them in office and they'll join together
in prayer in this case or in in in
aligning themselves with one another to
preserve to preserve their jobs and when
it comes to changing the system you'll
find members of opposing parties
agreeing more than disagreeing when the
alternative is is changing the system
and in ways that might eliminate their
their employment you have this from
expense reports for campaign 98 mm-hmm
filed with the Federal Election
Commission during 1993 how did you find
those FEC Federal Election Commission
senator Dale bumpers and Arkansas
Democrats spent over twenty seven
hundred dollars from his campaign fund
to rent an apartment in Little Rock that
serves as bumpers primary Arkansas
residents is that legal
to campaign if it's a campaign expense
and if you can make an argument for the
fact that this is a campaign expense
sure senator Frank Murkowski a
Republican from Alaska was reimbursed by
his campaign fund for more than fifteen
thousand an unspecified plane fare and
other travel expenses including three
hundred and five dollars for an
overnight stay in Tokyo what's wrong
with that nothing or do you list it
there I think people should know well if
it's a campaign expense it's a campaign
expense but I think people should know
that campaigns can go anywhere
congressional committees can go to
Barbados to discuss the implications of
a tax bill with insurance lobbyists
politicians travel far and wide in the
effort to be reelected Senator John
Breaux a Louisiana Democrat who had 1.5
million left in his campaign Treasury
after the 92 elections by the way can
they keep this forever
it can carry over paid himself a hundred
and six thousand nine hundred
twenty-five dollars for travel
restaurant and entertainment expenses
all related to his re-election bid in
1998 you have to start early bro also
reimbursed themselves $1,500 that he
paid to attend Mardi Gras events and
$1,050 for tickets to the New Orleans
Saints games public appearance related
to generating interest for his
reelection do people that give campaign
contributions know that these people
spend the money and the way you listed
it here some do some don't some some
don't care I think the the little man
may not may not know but I think some
people do and some people don't care
some lobbyists on gephardt's 167 63
person quote steering committee unquote
were reportedly asked to fork over
$2,500 each a cover charge that
represented a potential payday for the
honoree of more than 400 thousand
dollars what do you why did you release
that once again I think this is
interesting information people who vote
for politicians and
and maybe don't follow politics as much
as viewers of c-span
do don't don't know how important
fundraisers and social activities that
are aimed at raising money for
re-election campaigns are in this town
every night and you could eat free if
you put your mind to it in Washington
going from one fundraiser to another
Monday through Thursday and most of the
time without having to leave Capitol
Hill often you know people assume that
lobbyists are out there chasing members
of Congress tracking them down grabbing
them kicking and screaming into their
and into their offices to talk to them
about this piece of legislation or that
it's the other way around
it's the members of Congress who are
chasing after lobbyists when Daniel
Moynihan became after Benson left the
Senate to become Treasury Secretary and
Moynihan became chairman of the Senate
Finance Committee his office sent around
an invitation to lobbyists to come and
meet him and donate some money to his
his campaign coffers and the invitation
stressed how important he would be now
in his new position as chairman of the
Finance Committee and that 55% or 60% of
all tax and spending measures would
would filter through his committee so
you better get to know him when this
invitation got into the gut into the
media the event was canceled and you
know Moynihan's face must have turned
ten shades of scarlet and this is this
is part of the ugly business the ugly
behind-the-scenes business of raising
money that politicians don't like people
to know about and when they when people
find out about it when the press finds
out about it
lots of embarrassment can occur if a
chapter called welcome to the club and
it won't be long that there'll be a new
new club new members club new members
the average pay was seventy percent now
seventy percent per member but in the
case of the three House Democrats the
boost was bigger than that in other
words you get salary increase salary
don't what that 1992 what that
congressional House salary meant in
terms of a boost in personal income for
these new members
for breed night again I think it was 70%
the average was 70% but the case of
three House Democrats the boost was
bigger than that you know list Eva
Clayton who was making eight thousand
four she came to Congress Elizabeth
first of Oregon who was making five
thousand selling grapes and in
California dan dan Hamburg was making
twenty two hundred and sixty two on
unemployment on unemployment
compensation let me go back and read
that seventy percent of each new member
each new member back in 92 where there
were a hundred and ten new members right
this is Congress now not to skyress
increase their salary by 70 percent yeah
is it always been that way I couldn't
tell you it was just what made this
group interesting was that first of all
there were so many of them
secondly they came promising to reform
the system and stop talking to influence
peddlers and not take so much PAC money
they ended up the first six months this
new group of reform congressmen and
women was was in office they ended up
collecting 50 percent more money from
PACs than the preceding freshman class
let me summarize what about Pat cuz you
write a lot about pension how does it
work it's pretty cool are always change
to tell you the truth I don't know
what's going on right now with with PACs
but there is it there is this there is a
limit on the amount of money that
members of Congress can accept from PACs
it's five thousand dollars I believe are
they bad for well do you know their
their PACs covering everything their
bearer the sexual orientation PACs there
are snack food packs there are religious
packs there are golfing packs there are
grassroots packs there are a big
industry panel members would tell you
again if they were sitting here that
AIPAC is the most democratic way of
getting ready to have any power at all
by all putting bits and pieces of their
money in a pot in a pot and you
participate in the sharing of this money
it I don't I it looks bad to take lots
of PAC money I think congressmen
realized this looks bad to people many
see no alternative to payin and other
than taking PAC money to pay the
expenses for the incredible campaign
bill
that they incur when they run for
reelection pack the act the acronym has
become a bad word in politics another
way to get together the money you need
to run for reelection of course has had
to have the government pay and there was
an effort to minimize the influence of
PACs last year by increasing the amount
of money congressmen and Senators get
from the federal government to run for
re-election it's an area that needs to
be looked at and it's an area that needs
to be cleaned up but Congress of course
the only institution that can clean up
Congress is Congress itself in Congress
has shown over the years a tremendous
reluctance to get down and do they do
the hard work of cleaning up what PACs
do and the kind of money PACs can give
and other organizations can give to
members running for reelection you say
in the chapter on Caesar's Palace that
money in Washington is a byproduct of
relationships can you explain more about
that
well politics in Washington is a large
part of politics in Washington
politicking in Washington is is playing
a game it's going to lunch it's going
it's having fundraisers it's getting to
know people it's getting to know people
who can introduce you to other people
let's go into the right cocktail parties
where the right people are in attendance
and the right people always means people
with connections to to money a
Washington is a town where you you buy
access either by being influential
yourself or by paying for it there are
two things that get the attention of
members of Congress money and fear and
you're seeing in a way right now with
this election both of those things in
operation Congress members of Congress
probably have never been so afraid of
losing their jobs as they are right now
and they've never needed more money to
run more ads on television to influence
more voters that they should keep their
jobs but all of this Washington is a is
a is an is an immense buddy system you
become friends with people on the hill
once you've been in office for a while
you remain friends with those people
after you leave office so you can deal
with them and work with them and
influence them as a lobbyist
you're in your golden years when you're
no longer serving but need to have these
[ __ ] need to keep going back to the
cloakroom need to keep going to the
hospital or need to keep meeting these
people at fundraisers and receptions
anybody give you a strong negative
reaction to your book not so far
ever talk to a member about your book
not yet not yet when you travel and you
talk about the book do you find that
people out in the country know all these
stories I mean if you live here a lot of
these stories in your book are stuff
that we've sum up some of some have been
I heard about out in the out in the
country people are amazed by by what
goes on in Washington and and in some
cases less informed about what happens
here I think people in Washington who
live here and work here tend to accept a
lot of this as business as usual oh
so-and-so did that Oh so-and-so had to
resign or so-and-so was forced to give
this back next day is another day here
people who don't live in Washington or
people beyond the beltway tend to take
this after it sinks in a little more
serious and get very very upset angry
you get angry phone calls I've been on
some talk shows recently in other parts
of the country and the anger that that
callers and viewers express it's just
amazing it stunned me that people are as
upset and agitated about not only their
members who have always in the past had
people have hated Congress in general at
least polls suggest that that but but
have sort of liked their own members
have appreciated the work their own
members have done for them but the anger
that this is not scientific but any
means.the anger that you hear from from
people about Congress in general and
their own senators and congressmen it's
it stunned me are you angry not
particularly no and then I suppose it's
a little outrageous and they behave
you're asked in but I've lived here too
long I guess in a way to be completely
outraged by it but I'm stunned by what
what amazes me is the and this will
always amaze me I think is the ability
of members of Congress or House of
Representatives in the Senate once
they've had a scandal a break in
in their you know in their lives their
ability just to go out and face the
public as if nothing has happened the
the ability to act their way through
through scandals and through expose as
if once we're in another it fascinates
me there's almost a sort of penitential
chic that that is an operation on
Capitol Hill the worse the scandal the
greater the opportunity to appear human
and it's that it's that appearing human
and that ability to act your way through
a scandal money scandal a behavioural
scandal that to me is just absolutely
amazing maybe maybe the voting public is
so accustomed to afternoon television
into Donahue and Sally Jessy and Maury
and Oprah that all of this now is just
seen as part of this American
dysfunctional ISM that we have to accept
and embrace but members of Congress have
really learned how to how to do this
very well I think that's what I don't
know if you called it outrage but that's
what really amazes me this ability to to
have something awful happen in your
career or personal life and then the
next day pretend as if nothing has
happened and go on with your business
ah straight fed yeah no we never met you
know I don't I have any idea what you're
about to say this but I'd be interested
in your perception of what televising
the congressman in fact has had on the
public sure positive negative oh very
positive I think the more there should
be more of it obviously I don't know
what else you could show and c-span
because you seem to show everything I
remember once I was getting back to this
freshman orientation thing you had a
camera on a bus that was taking
Republican new incoming Republican
members to a meeting and Annapolis for a
Republican orientation program I
couldn't believe it I thought where else
does c-span the next the next place will
be the men's room I guess but see spins
so shows so much it's hard to imagine
what else you could sow but sure no
everyone's people see the more educated
they are as to what's going on I think
c-span's played a big unsolicited
testimonial here it's played a big part
in exposing the reality of politics and
the reality of Capitol Hill rituals and
the reality of what goes on here
to more people than ever before and
people the more people see the more they
don't like but let me take it the other
turn on because this really my question
wasn't about the positive negative of
whether we're even there is it the
members over there some would say that
by showing this process up close is not
a positive and you can't ever get a
perfect situation and the public again
gets a distorted view because again when
the chamber is empty in there during
special orders they're on doing other
things like going to committee meetings
they can't be able placed at one time
right I guess that's the what are the
members think well I think a lot of them
a lot of them said again as an
opportunity to perform I'm you talking
about special orders I remember Dornan's
performance is kind of one-man Late Show
during the 92 presidential campaign when
he just sort of held court every night
doing doing a number on Bill Clinton for
weeks and weeks and weeks a lot of
members see this is an opportunity to
perform to generate sound bytes look the
important thing they have to do is get
on the air and one way for members of
Congress to do that is to is to create
some drama to create a crisis or an
emergency situation bring it up on the
floor of the house or the Senate hope
that the network's pick it up carol
moseley-braun did this with the remember
the renewal of the of the trademark for
the Daughters of the Confederacy she she
took that issue ran with it made a made
an emergency crisis out of it got on
television this is this is what
television has done for for the House
and Senate but it's given it's given
congressman one more way to perform it
couldn't that be a negative well I mean
when people perform they reveal a lot
about themselves and the more the more
someone's onstage the more you see about
him and one of these people of course
don't know when to leave the stage which
is a big part of show business you have
to know when to shut up and and those
who don't know that tend to put their
feet in their mouth as Dornan did when
he when he did his Late Show you have a
chapter and we'll switch the subject
similarly all about the Library of
Congress and in driving Clarion of
Congress James Billington how compton
Billington has has always interested me
I'm interested in Rush
and Russian culture Russian politics
Billington is a Russian scholar and
that's what started it I did a profile
of Billington for the LA Times magazine
a couple of years ago and was at a party
that he gave at at the Library of
Congress ostensibly to open a Harriman
Collection there were some letters and
documents that Averell Harriman had
donated the Library of Congress than
this collection was being made available
to scholars and billing so Billington
saw this as an opportunity to have a
cocktail party and he invited people I
couldn't believe I was seeing some of
these people George Kennan Richard Helms
McNamara
Pamela hem is like and it was a couple
of months after the after the coup had
failed and the Soviet Union was on the
way out at this point and it was almost
like a victory party I got asked who it
was George Kennan George Kennan is the
father of the containment theory George
Kennan was a former wizard still is a
Soviet ologist a Russian scholar
McNamara was a former Robert McNamara
former Secretary of Defense Richard Howe
and Richard Helms former head of the CIA
it was almost like a victory party a
victory over communism party but you
could see Billington working the crowd
the Library of Congress has tanned there
were some members of Congress there from
the committee that oversees the funding
for the library and these are people
that Billington has to curry favor with
but but Billington was working the crowd
in a way that I've never really seen
anybody do that before in the Washington
cocktail circuit I used to be the editor
of dossier magazine which no longer
exists and the purpose of dossier was to
sort of cover the Washington social
scene so I've seen a lot of cocktail
circuitry and I'd never seen anyone so
good at it is Billington this one
particular night from his rumpled tuxedo
that said I need money to just his
ingratiating manner it was amazing to
watch and then I started to look more
and more into what Billington had done
and Billington must have been the envy
of every member of Congress now here
Billington is not subject to the same
kind of money raising restrictions that
members of Congress are and Billington's
Christ created the Madison Council to
raise money for the
this is all for extracurricular kind of
library things like exhibits and events
and members of the Madison Council could
pay anywhere from 10,000 to $100,000 a
year for the opportunity to hold parties
themselves there at the library which is
one of the great party venues in
Washington if if sort of atmospherics is
is everything in Washington and
atmospherics that would help you create
interest in giving you money so you can
do great works the Library of Congress
is a great place for parties anything
wrong with anything he's done so far did
you say that he was trying to change a
procedure so that people would pay a
user fee for some of the things
Billington wanted to dismiss is I don't
know if this is right or wrong I mean
that requires maybe a philosopher to
decide that but Billington wanted to
char here the Library of Congress needs
money to do the things it does it
provides the Library of Congress
provides a lot of free services to
companies that take this information and
turn around and sell it for they have to
pay for it in they don't have to pay for
it no copyright free well it depends on
what the information is but the Library
of Congress just generates lots and lots
of information that data banks and
resources and research services then
turn around and sell to their customers
and Billington wants a piece of the
action I can't blame them you say that
they have four hundred million dollar a
year budget they get from the government
approach two times four hundred million
yeah they have four hundred five hundred
and thirty two miles of shelves a
hundred million items and that they have
the personal papers about twenty three
presents and a thousand members of
Congress and of course Billington is
very good at at getting new material all
that and of course new material is
flooding into the Library of Congress
one of the big problems there is is
cataloging all this stuff it's called
arrearage all of the information all of
the books pamphlets whatever that have
not yet been cataloged and available for
for you know research Billington as
matter of fact was in moscow during the
coup in August of 1991 and he had
there's a Library of Congress office as
a congressional research office in
Moscow I don't know if it's still in
operation but it was and Billington was
had set this up to to sort of help the
the Duma the russian congress organize
itself and create some research material
itself and during the coup Billington
while Billington is sort of watching all
of this stuff and participating on the
fringes of all of this he had people
from the Library of Congress out picking
up leaflets and flyers and manifestos
and pamphlets really kind of a
historians dream come true and he was
out there with his forces
street-sweeping for material electric
and gun but what happened to his
proposal that people in business would
have to pay shut down of course why well
people in business who sell information
are generally big campaign contributors
the big campaign contributors don't want
to have competition from the Library of
Congress the big campaign contributors
who give money to important members of
committees that might oversee the
activity of the Library of Congress said
this is a this is not a good thing
and Billington came before the committee
that oversees the library asked for
permission to sell some of this
information and got a resounding no
because there's a new Congress soon to
come in let me go back to something you
quoted from members it came in in 1992
here's maria cantwell
a Democrat from Tom Foley's home state
of Washington will be a force to be
reckoned with watch out what happened
they weren't quite the force to be
reckoned with that they promised to be
once again very shortly it's very
difficult to be a force to be reckoned
with when you're operating outside the
system on in Congress I this was
something she said of course before she
got here and once she got here once
other members got here they saw how hard
it would be to work outside the system
to change the system as Outsiders is
literally and they're no Outsiders I
mean if you don't have a power base if
you don't play you're if you don't play
party politics you're not going to be
helped with your campaign your
re-election campaign if you don't go
along you don't if you don't get along
you don't go along and you don't go
along you don't get along and if you
don't do the things that are necessary
to keep the system working properly
you're not gonna find yourself able to
do much of anything do you really mean
the following statement the main concern
of every Washington politician is job
security yeah yes I do yeah sure you
mean they're not here for their
constituents
it's there's a very thin line between
public service and self-service
constituents are a means to an end for
most politicians khun's most politicians
have very very little respect for the
quote people who send them who send them
here they like to talk to them they like
to speak to them they like to shake
their hands they like lots of them
around when they appear in public but
what the I think if you if it once again
I look at what the Fred Grandy said the
other day Fred Grandy the congressman
from Love Boat who who tried to become
the governor of Iowa didn't work and
he's now leaving the hill like most
people who leave Congress he had a lot
to say about how Congress doesn't work
what's what's funny now is how
congressmen especially ex-congressman
former congressmen and Senators
returning to blame constituents
constituents need to know more about the
about how bills become law constituents
need to know more about what goes on
here become more sophisticated before
they judge us I just I don't think that
that congressman care much about voters
until it comes time to count votes
election at election time what do you
what do you say to people watching that
are angry and expect a vote this time
around will create change in January
what are the chances well they'd better
wake up and sort of realize what does
create change if fear is one of the
things that motivates members of
Congress to act or to change themselves
to change their act may be a constant
message from voters will work after a
while but as this last class of
so-called reformers have shown electing
reformers doesn't always create the kind
of reform on Capitol Hill that route
that did outsiders now become insiders
promised to bring to the job when they
come here
it just doesn't work the way it's
supposed to at least the way people
running for office say it well you say
well not exactly giving the House and
Senate a triple-a rating for trust and
integrity Ornstein and man make it sound
as though it's misguided Outsiders it is
misguided Outsiders who are doing all
the harm Tom man
and Norman Ornstein whoo-wee Norman
Artie's been here on booknotes but we've
seen both gentlemen many many times in
the national media being quoted what was
your point there that those two did a
Ornstein works at the American
Enterprise Institute of a think tank in
Washington and Thomas Mann not that not
the novelist works at the Brookings
Institute and the two of them got
together and wrote up I guess it's a
pamphlet or a booklet on reforming
Congress and they there's an
introduction to that and they talk about
Congress bashing and that that the
country has become obsessed with
Congress with bashing Congress the way
to reform Congress is not to bash it but
to do the hard work necessary to change
the institution one of the points they
sort they overlooked and don't really
make and this is a problem I think with
the Washington media you can look at
something so long from the inside you
don't really see it anymore
the Congress bashers are not not the the
great mass of American voters out there
as members of Congress them so this is
how you get reelected you bash Congress
Congress is full of the biggest congress
basher is imaginable this is the one of
the ways one of the tried and true ways
you run for reelection I think what's so
funny now about this current election is
how desperately all of all of the people
up for up for reelection the 33 senators
or 35 Senators how many however many it
is and in the entire house how they're
trying to distance themselves from what
they've been doing the act of running
for re-election now if we're running
running for your old job or to get your
old job back is the act of sorting
pretending that you never had the job in
the first place so it's not the people
who are bashing Congress if they are
they're taking a cue from four members
of Congress and do a pretty good job on
their own this is the book called Club
fed power money sex and violence on
Capitol Hill our author guest has been
built Thomas we thank you thank you very
much